on va passer tout de suite à l'invité du
soir ce soir on va revenir sur la guerre
au sein de la famille de Lon pendant les
fêtes ça a totalement explosé entre les
différents membres de la famille Antony
Anthony a déposé une main courante
contre sa demi-sœur Anouka Anouka elle
porortait plainte contre Anthony alain a
également porté plainte contre son fils
et les plaintes contre iromi ont été
classés sans suite alors il faut nous
expliquer tout ça il y a Fabien lekuv
qui va venir pourquoi que se passe-t-il
au sein de la famille on en parle ce
soir avec Fabien lekuv puis on sera avec
chamy exgarde du corps d'Alain Delon euh
il a été ça a été le le plus proche
voilà de toutes les donc là voilà je
vous le dis il a tout et vous allez voir
les rvélation qui va nous faire il nous
dira la
vérité sa vérité sur cette histoire
puisque c'était un des plus proches de
la famille il sera là dans un instant
c'est vraiment une exclu pour TPMP mais
avant tout regardez les déclarations
d'Antony Delon c'était sur C news bien
entendu regardez le fait qu'elle ne nous
ait pas communiqué ces cinq tests
cognitifs appelés test de démence pour
moi c'est très très grave pourquoi parce
que un si elle nous les avait communiqué
on aurait agi plutôt dans laa faire
Rolin
deux si elleous si elle nous les avait
communiqué on les aurait donné à la
gendarmerie on les aurait inclus dans la
plainte en disant attention regardez ce
qui se passe pour moi éthiquement c'est
très grave voilà d'abord un de nous
avoir menti nous avoir manipulé elles
seront complice indirect de Rolin euh
parce qu'elle a laissé mon père là-bas
si vous voulez mon père on l'a récupéré
dans un état euh physique psychologique
de délabrement de de il était très
touché merci euh Fabi LEF d'être avec
nous auteur et biographe qu'on connaît
bien ici et je voudrais remercier
également chamy d'être avec nous c'est
vraiment une excuse vous avez pris
l'avion juste pour venir nous voir merci
beaucoup et votre témoignage va être
très très important ce soir merci d'être
là c'est vraiment une exclu euh Fabien
Lek est-ce que moi voilà je je débarque
par exemple qu'est-ce qui se passe parce
qu'on ne parle que de ça qu'est-ce qui
se passe à 20h54 en direct au sein de la
famille à Delon c'est un des plus grands
acteurs français voilà il fait partie
des tro qu plus grands acteurs français
de tous les temps qu'est-ce qui se passe
il faut peut-être remonter au au 4
janvier de cette année d'accord lorsque
Paris Match sort sa couve avec Anthony
Delon qui accuse finalement sa sœur dem
sa demi-sœur oui enfin sa sœur sa sœur
il accuse de de mensonge et de
manipulation à partir de là commence une
affaire familiale on avait déjà connu ça
avec l'affaire àid tout le monde le sait
euh c'est inévitable aujourd'hui parce
que je pense que ça fait partie
aujourd'hui les médias sont utilisés
souvent on jette on jette un peu le S
sal sur les médias mais non c'est
l'inverse et c'est quoi l'histoire en
fait non mais raconte-nous ben
c'est-à-dire que euh il y a une
succession qui est compliquée il y a
trois enfants qui viennent de de deux
unions différentesc il y a une première
union avec Nathalie
Delon c'est le donc ils ont eu un fils
Alain Delon et Nathalie Delon un fils
qui s'appelle Anthony Delon qui est né
en 1964 comme c'est sur le le schéma et
puis après il est il a eu une autre
réunion avec Rosalie Alain Delon avec
deux autres enfants Anouchka qui était
né en 90 et puis son frère Alain Fabien
qui est né en 1994 oui c'est ça d'accord
donc ben c'est déjà très compliqué quand
il y a plusieurs enfants de plusieurs
lites c'est déjà difficile oui mais
c'est c'est quoi l'histoire alors le
l'éritage il y a c'est quoi et ben à la
suite du Paris Match finalement il y a
eu une une réponse qui a été faite enfin
d'abord d'abord anthony est venu sur un
plateau télé je pense à C news au côté
de Pascal pro il s'est expliqué en fait
il était extrêmement sincère d'ailleurs
on peut le reconnaître touché sincère et
puis voilà il a il a motivé un petit peu
son action parce qu'il avait déposé le 7
novembre de l'année 2023 il avait posé
une main courante au dans un
commissariat contre sa sœur pour
mensonge et manipulation ou mais on
comprend rien c'est quoi l'histoire
c'est quoi les mon c'est quoi la
manipulation on aimerait bien savoir moi
je débarque je comprends rien c'est quoi
l'histoire parce que vous me parlez là
comme si on était tous au courant de
l'histoire moi je comprends rien je vous
dis donc racontez-nous l'histoire
Bernard Montiel c'est quoi l'histoire
non l'histoire c'est c'est comme l'a dit
Anthony bien souligné c'est pas une
histoire d'argent V on s'en fout c'est
pas comme il l'a dit c'est quoi
l'histoire on comprend rien l'histoire
c'est c'est c'est que Anthony a dégainé
avec et il a bien fait avec une main
courante parce que il a estimé que
raconte-nous l'istoire par qu'il compr
je comprends rienaconoustoire qu'il nous
parle la main courante c'est quoi
l'istoire pour les téléspectateurson est
malade il va très mal merci voilà iliss
faire voilà il ne peut plus parler il
n'est pas remis de son AVC il a un lit
médicalisé il est souvent en fauteuil
roulant et on a l'impression que ces
trois enfants se déchirent propos de la
santé d'alin Delon et surtout derrière
tout ça de l'héritage l'héritage est
extraordinairementlexe mais on parle on
parle de 300 plus de 300 millions il y
aurait 320 330 millions d'euros IL3 BCH
oui il faut savoir qu'Alain Delon avait
fait des affaires dans l'immobilier par
exemple il y avait un triplex au pied de
la tour effffel qu' l' a revendu 46
millions d'euros il y a des une demeure
sompteuse à Genève il y avait une
demeure à Marrakech qui a été revendue
il y a des tableaux il y a eu des ventes
aux enchères il y a une collection de
tableaux de monstres des corau des
guériicot des très grands peintres qui
qui l'a vendu il y a la demeure de
Douchy donc voilà il y a un patrimoine
immobilier des collections lui il a été
il a eu sa société de production 90
films metteurs en scène donc voilà
autour de ça les trois enfants se
déchirent pourquoi parce que sa fille
Anouchka va recevoir 50 % de l'héritage
mais fait ce qu'il veut s'il veut donner
50 % oui mais je j'explique pourquoi il
y a un malaise de la part des garçons
parce quex ont chacun 25 % donc derrière
t ça il y a un vrai malaise parce que
les garçons se sentent lesésés spolés
par unouchka qui est la fille préférée
voilà c'est la petite préférée depuis
toutis compléter ce que dit g non il y a
un autre malaise dont personne ne parle
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est que
Anouchka est également vice-présidente
puis présidente des entreprises à l'in
delelon oui et je vais compléter ce que
dit justement Gilles Verdez parce que
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent c'est-à-dire que les
entreprises Deon c'est du champagne ça
été des cigarettes en 2018 qui gère
c'est du parfum bah si c'est non mais
c'est un chiffre d'affaires très
important il il fait ce qu'il veut si
veut dire bien sûr qu'il bien sûr il
fait ce qu'ils veut de long mais en même
temps c'est de l'argent considérable par
exemple la vente aux enchères qui a eu
lieu le 22 juin l'année dernière 2023 il
y a eu pour 8 millions de tableaux qui
ont été vendus il y a eu un duffi 16 il
y a eu un Eugène de la croix à 700000
depuis 2000 2007 il y a des ventes aux
encherres multiples qui ont été organisé
pour les biens d'unindelon les armes le
vin les tableaux leson Bugatti qui onit
quand Mme 4 milli ça fait plus de 25
millions rien qu'en vente aux enchères
alors justement Gill l'histoire c'est
quoi pourquoi Anthony Delon dépose
plainte contre sa demi-sœur c'est ça
qu'on veut savoir alors il y a eu
d'abord donc iromy Rolin qui est sorti
du bois c'est c'est la l'exgouvernante
qui se décrit comme la compagne d'Alain
Delon qui donc a été éjecté de la maison
de douchi qui a porté plainte pour
violence et les enfants on porté plainte
contre elle en disant qu'elle abusait de
la faiblesse d'Alain Delon et bien tout
ça é cl sans suite il y a pas
d'infraction donc on va dire match nul
au niveau judiciaire mais homirolin s'en
sort quand même très bien parce qu'à un
moment on pensait qu'elle pourrait être
condamnée tout ça est effacé mais
maintenant les enfants se déchirent
parce que les deux garçons voilà ne
supportent pas qu'ka soit la préféré et
donc ça va très mal entre eux et ça va
de mal en pied avec des déclarations
Anouchka porte plainte contre Anthony et
on a l'impression que le feuilleton ne
va faire queir plus Glo encore pour
compléter pardon que tu disais mais
c'est que Anthony Delon demande la
tutelle que son père soit mis sous
tutelle protection juridique parce qu'il
estime qu'il est plus apte ce que tu
disais au tout début d'Urs de l'histoire
c'est qu'il est plus hte finalement à
organisé à gérer sa vie et et Anouka ne
veut pas mettre son père sous tutelle
parce que les les sociétés d' vont aussi
être contrôlé dont elle est la
présidente alors tout le problème est là
c'est qu'il y a des enjeux derrière sa
pas qui vrai qui faut alors justement
moi je voilà moi Mouka j'ai souvent je
suis souvent en contact avec elle elle
m' l'air extrêmement sincère en tout cas
et euh voilà et malè en tout cas elle
m'a ditelle c'est la plus proche de son
père c'est celle qui reste le plus avec
son père elle m'a dit et voilà qu'elle
s'occupait euh de son père à fond et
qu'elle était elle m'a l'air en tout cas
extrêmement euh euh Anouchka voilà elle
m'a l'air extrêmement sincère